-Donald Trump took
the stand today
for an angry
and combative appearance
in his New York fraud trial,
marking the first time
he's faced direct questioning
from prosecutors in court
as part of a sprawling case
that could wipe out
his entire business empire.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Just to recap,
throughout his presidency,
Donald Trump was consistently
the most disliked president
in the history of polling.
He lost the popular vote
by 3 million the first time
and 7 million the second time.
He cost the GOP the House
in 2018 and the Senate in 2020.
His hand-picked candidates
in 2022 were rejected
and humiliated in almost
every single race
where he played a major role.
He got impeached twice,
oversaw a disastrous
and incompetent response to a
once-in-a-generation pandemic.
He orchestrated a coup attempt
and incited a riotous mob
to storm the Capitol
that threatened to kill
his own vice president
and install him
as an unelected dictator.
He's facing four separate
criminal cases,
as well as a civil fraud trial
that could erase
his entire business empire.
And on top of all that,
he's the weirdest human
being on the planet.
So naturally, after all that,
he is finally slinking away
from the national spotlight
in disgrace to face consequences
for his behavior.
And I'm just kidding.
He's leading in the [bleep]
polls again by like a lot.
-In the race
for the White House,
new polls are showing
some very unfavorable trends
for President Biden.
The latest CBS news poll
of likely voters
finds President Trump slightly
ahead of President Biden.
-A "New York Times" poll of
six battleground states that
President Biden
won back in 2020.
Now, in five out of six of those
states, Mr. Biden
is trailing Donald Trump.
He's behind by five in Arizona,
six in Georgia and a startling
10 points in Nevada.
He's even trailing in states
like Michigan and Pennsylvania,
where the president has seen
strong Democratic support.
-This brings us to
a new segment we're calling
"Seth Stares Off
Into The Distance
And Mutters To Himself
For A Second."
[ Laughter ]
[ Muttering ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Biden's old,
but Trump's old, too.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, like...
Really...
[ Laughter and applause ]
I mean, some people say, "Oh,
this will be good for you,"
but get that out of your head.
[ Laughter ]
This isn't a real cigarette.
This has been "Seth Stares Off
Into The Distance
And Mutters To Himself
For A Second."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, I know we are a full year
away from the election,
and it's natural and normal
for people
to express
their frustration
with the incumbent
at this point in the calendar.
The same thing happened
with Obama too,
and then he went on
to easily defeat Mitt Romney.
In fact, Gallup's final poll
before the election
had Romney ahead,
so there's no reason to panic.
On the other hand, we have to
start [bleep] panicking now!
We are [bleep], [bleep],
[bleep], [bleep]!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So, I guess this new poll
makes Trump the front runner,
not just for the GOP nomination,
but for the whole deal.
Yeah. I mean, okay, cool.
What a world.
That would mean
the current front runner
to be the next president
spent the day in court
where he was grilled
on the stand by prosecutors
about his company's
alleged widespread fraud.
And this morning,
when he arrived in court,
he did his usual Trump shtick,
where he complained
about the proceedings
and lashed out
at everyone involved.
Maybe you should spend
less time coming up with names
for things and more time
coming up with a defense.
"Mr. President, we have
to explain to the judge
how you came up
with this net worth estimate."
"I call it warfare or lawfare.
Or how about this one?
Law not fair.
[ Laughter ]
I was up all night
for that one."
So far, the entirety
of the Trump defense
has basically been
that they had no idea
what was going on
at their own company.
Last week, Trump's
two oldest sons,
who were officers
at the company,
pleaded ignorance
when they took the stand.
-Two of Trump's sons,
Don Jr., Eric as well,
who are
executive vice presidents
at the Trump Organization,
they both testified this week.
Both made arguments
that were nearly identical,
that it was the company's
accountants who,
in fact, were responsible
for issues
with financial statements,
not them.
-I'm apparently guilty of fraud
for relying on my accountants
to do, wait for it, accounting.
I mean, think about that.
What does that do for literally
any other business?
You pay experts millions
of dollars to be experts.
You sign off
on what they give you.
-That's, wait for it,
not how it works.
[ Laughter ]
By the way, I'd be fine if we
instituted automatic jail time
for anyone who does wait
for it in 2023.
They're accountants.
You give them information,
and then they just
prepare the statements.
They're not the ones
running your business.
You're supposed to be
in charge of them.
Also, you can't believably say
you employ experts
when your family
is also employed
the law firm of weirdo,
goofball and nuts.
Oh, no. Was Rudy Giuliani
also your accountant?
"Good news, boss,
I just did all the numbers,
and it's a unicorn.
[ Laughter ]
I was -- I'm as surprised
as you were, boss.
[ Laughter ]
It's a mythical creature.
Now we have proof."
[ Laughter ]
The other defense
they've been using before today
is that Trump's children
should be left alone,
even though two of them
were officers of the company
who signed off
on the statements in question.
-Trump is accusing
Attorney General James
of harassing him
and his children.
-Mr. Trump
is lashing out online,
saying leave
my children alone.
-And now these children
are being brought in away
from their families for
doing nothing wrong.
-These poor innocent, lightly
bearded children
are being brought in alone.
Their nannies
have to wait outside,
which means they're going hours
between snacks.
It is shameful.
But today it was
Trump's turn to take the stand,
and let's just pause
for a moment
to appreciate
how dramatic it is.
A former president being grilled
in court about systemic,
years long fraud at his company,
which is the entire basis
of his fortune
and his image as a supposedly
successful businessman.
And this isn't even
one of the four criminal cases.
This is just a civil case.
We've become so inured
to Trump's flagrant
lawbreaking and insanity
that it barely registers
as news anymore.
If Martin Van Buren
had been dragged into court
on fraud allegations,
that would be the only thing
anyone remembers about it.
Instead, all anyone
remembers about him
is the "Seinfeld" episode.
Or that's the only thing
Sal remembers about it.
[ Laughter ]
And I'm sure it won't shock you
to learn that Trump was both
combative and uncooperative
during his testimony today.
In fact, this morning
he couldn't even make it
through the first
half hour of testimony
without repeatedly
picking fights with the judge
and getting yelled at.
-Happening now,
behind those doors,
Donald Trump has been testifying
in the civil fraud trial
against him.
He's been on the stand
for about 25 minutes or so.
He has been admonished
by the judge.
He has criticized the judge.
The judge has told him to stick
to answering
the questions in this,
all within the first
minutes of testimony.
-That's how it started.
They couldn't even make it
25 minutes
without having to wrangle him
like they're trying
to give medicine to a cat.
He was supposedly
the Commander in Chief.
He can't even get through
one day in court
without getting into
like nine different fights
within the first 25 minutes.
He's like a blue collar dad
at a fancy restaurant,
immediately furious
he didn't get bread right away.
"What kind of horse hockey
is this?
I want butter, not a dish
full of chopped up olives.
And why the hell
is everyone wearing a suit?
This is a restaurant,
not a funeral.
Of course,
I wouldn't be surprised
if someone dropped dead
when they saw these prices.
Screw this,
I'm going to the Golden Corral."
I told the valet guy just tell
me where you parked it."
[ Laughter ]
In fact, things got so heated
that at one point
the judge
had to turn away from Trump
and appealed to his lawyers
to get him to behave.
Now, because there are
no cameras inside,
we can't actually
see what happens,
so we have to rely
on narration from reporters
on even the smallest gestures
or facial expressions.
-Let's get back out
to the courthouse.
Paula Reid's got some
more detail from inside.
What's happening?
-This is getting pretty heated.
The judge asking
Trump's lawyer,
"Can you control your client?
This is not a political rally."
This coming from our colleagues
who are inside
the courtroom
watching this live.
The judge forcing
Trump's lawyer, Chris Kise,
to talk to the former president.
The former president,
we're reading here,
apparently waved his arms
at any suggestion
of taking a 10 minute break.
He is sitting back in his chair,
we're told,
just pursing his lips in that
sort of classic Trump smile.
Trump's lawyer is assuring
the judge
that their client
"understands the rules."
The judge shot back and said,
"Well, he doesn't
abide by them."
Now, apparently they're back
into questioning.
-This is kind of
a frustrating way
to hear what's
going on in court.
It's like listening
to hockey on NPR.
Like, you know,
the action is crazy,
but it's so confusing
to listen to.
Let's see, we're getting more
reporting from the courthouse.
Yes, Mr. Trump waved
his hands and pursed his lips.
Then he moved them in and out
like he was playing
an invisible accordion.
Then he began drawing
little boxes with his fingers
and pointing to his head,
saying, "I understand the rules.
I have them all up here
in my big brain."
Then the judge shot back,
"You're not acting
like you know the rules."
Then Trump said, "Am, too."
And the judge said, "Am not."
Then Trump said "Am, too."
Then the judge said, "Am not."
Then Trump said, "It smells
like updog in here."
Then the judge said,
"I'm not falling for that."
Then Trump said,
"I don't know, dog.
What's up with you?"
Then the judge said, "You can't
just act like I fell for it.
Loser says what?"
Then Trump said, "What?"
Then the judge said,
"You said what.
That means you're a loser."
Then Trump got angry
and screamed, "This is warfare!
No, wait. It's lawfare.
No wait. It's law unfair."
Then he got up and tried
to storm out of the courtroom,
but his tie got stuck
in the door
and he fell backwards
and split his pants
and threw up on himself,
and the judge called a recess.
And Trump said,
"The judge [bleep] in my pants."
And the judge said,
"No, I didn't."
Then Trump said, "Then how
did [bleep] get in my pants?"
Then the judge said,
"Maybe it was updog."
Then Trump said,
"What's updog?"
Then the judge said, "I don't
know. what's up with you?"
And the entire courtroom
laughed.
[ Laughter ]
Back to you, Kate.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Although I guess
the judge's warning
did start to sink in with Trump
at some point
because as he left the courtroom
for a morning break,
reporters tried
to ask him a question
and he just made a lip seal
gesture as he walked away.
-Mr. Trump,
has it going in there?
[ Laughter ]
-He could have said no comment
like a grown up,
but of course he did
a goofy gesture
like an eighth-grade girl
who knows about your crush.
The only time he's made
that gesture in his life
was when his kids asked him
to read a bedtime story.
"Sorry, boys.
I'm under a gag order."
The 2024 presidential election
is still a year away,
and a lot can happen,
but no one should doubt
that as of this moment,
Trump could very well win,
which would give him the power
to pardon himself,
essentially
erase his indictments,
and officially declare himself
above the law.
Again,
as we've seen before,
a lot can change and will change
between now and next November.
So when it comes
to the election,
all we can do for now is just
stay calm while we...
-Wait for it.
[ Laughter ]
This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, everybody. Thanks for
watching "A Closer Look."
And as a reminder,
my brother Josh
and I have started a new podcast
called "Family Trips"
with the Meyers Brothers.
We hope you listen.
We hope you like it,
and see you soon.